Brad Pitt just said recently someone
asked him who did he think is the most
good-looking person in the world he goes
that would be George Clooney well he's
right about that let's face it he's
right your best friend oh pretty boy pit
you're talking pretty boy pit exactly we
actually have a clip of of Mr Pitt let's
this this burned up the internet
recently can you share this place who
are the most handsome men in the world
past and present if I was going to name
someone present well I got to name that
George Clooney [__] because usually
I'm always taking him out and he's
always taking me out and this time I'm
going to go the other way just this once
for a moment that he's correct well you
are one of the most handsome men do you
have anything to say about him well I do
have some things to say about him um and
it will include the word in it
apparently I think the truth is he was
just the first time he answered it he
said himself and they said maybe don't
say that yeah do another day yeah um and
I would say that I too think that I am
the most handsome man
so nice of you to agree
no I will say this
you know not modest but I'm very funny